for the solution within forecastfragment
we implemented fetchweathertask
which extends async tasks the generics
we use are just void and this is fine
for now then within the do and
background method we copied our
networking code snippet here it's the
same except that in certain cases we
return null instead of setting the
forecast JSON string to be null
previously the code was in oncreate view
which expected us to inflate in return
of you so it's important that it got to
the rest of the code even if there was
an error in the networking code now that
the networking code is an async task
there's really nothing that comes after
this and the doing background method so
it's fine to just bail early whenever
there's an error also note that for our
log messages we've defined a log tag
constant at the top of this task this
log tag is defined to be the name of the
fetchweathertask class the reason we use
this syntax instead of declaring a
string fetchweathertask
is because we want these two to be in
sync if you ever rename the class then
it will throw an exception unless you
also update it here